ont dit qu'ils avaient peur. Je ne sais pas si j'ai peur,
mais c'est la première fois que je m'adresse à une audience comme celle-ci.
Et je n'ai rien de technologiquement intelligent à vous montrer.
Il n'y a pas de transparents, vous aurez à vous contenter de moi.
(Rires)
Ce que je veux faire ce matin, c'est partager quelques histoires avec vous
et parler d'une Afrique différente.
Ce matin déjà il y a eu plusieurs allusions à l'Afrique
dont vous entendez tout le temps parler : l'Afrique du VIH/SIDA,
l'Afrique du paludisme, l'Afrique de la pauvreté, l'Afrique des conflits,
et l'Afrique des catastrophes.
Bien qu'il soit vrai que ces choses se produisent,
il y a une Afrique dont vous n'entendez pas beaucoup parler.
Et parfois je suis perplexe, et je me demande pourquoi.
C'est l'Afrique qui change, celle à laquelle Chris a fait allusion.
C'est l'Afrique des opportunités.
C'est l'Afrique où les gens veulent prendre en main
leurs propres futurs et leurs propres destinées.
Et c'est l'Afrique où les gens sont à la recherche de partenariats
pour y arriver. Voilà ce dont je veux parler aujourd'hui.
Et je souhaite commencer en vous racontant
une histoire à propos de ce changement en Afrique.
Le 15 septembre 2005, M. Diepreye Alamieyeseigha,
un gouverneur d'un des états du Nigeria les plus riches en pétrole,
fût arrêté par la London Metropolitan Police au cours d'une visite à Londres.
Il fût arrêté parce qu'il y avait des transferts de 8 millions de dollars
allant sur certains comptes inactifs
lui appartenant ainsi qu'à sa famille.
Cette arrestation se produisit grâce à la coopération
entre la London Metropolitan Police
et la Commission Nigériane contre les Crimes Économiques et Financiers --
dirigée par un de nos gens les plus capables et courageux : M. Nuhu Ribadu.
Alamieyeseigha fût traduit en justice à Londres.
À cause de certaines gaffes, il parvint à s'échapper déguisé en femme
et s'enfuit de Londres pour rejoindre le Nigeria où
en accord avec notre constitution, ceux qui exercent une fonction officielle
en tant que gouverneurs, président -- comme dans beaucoup de pays --
possèdent une immunité et ne peuvent pas être poursuivis. Mais ce qui s'est passé:
les gens étaient si scandalisés par ces agissements qu'il fût possible
pour l'assemblée législative de l'état de le mettre en accusation et de le destituer.
Aujourd'hui, Alams -- pour faire court -- est en prison.
C'est une histoire sur le fait que les gens en Afrique
ne sont plus disposés à tolérer la corruption de leurs dirigeants.
C'est une histoire sur le fait que les gens veulent que leurs ressources
soient convenablement gérées pour leur bien, et non pas transférées vers des endroits
où ils ne profiteront qu'à une petite élite.
Donc, quand vous entendez parler de l'Afrique corrompue --
toujours la corruption -- je veux que vous sachiez que les gens
et les gouvernements essayent sérieusement de lutter contre
dans certains de ces pays, et qu'il en ressort certains succès.
Cela veut-il dire que le problème est résolu ? La réponse est non.
Il reste encore beaucoup de chemin à faire mais la volonté est là.
Et des succès sont remportés dans ce combat très important.
Donc quand vous entendez parler de corruption,
ne pensez pas que rien n'est fait --
que vous ne pouvez pas opérer dans aucun pays africains
à cause de la corruption massive. Ce n'est pas le cas.
Il y a une volonté de lutter, et dans de nombreux pays, cette lutte est en cours
et est en train d'être gagnée. Dans d'autres, comme le mien,
le Nigeria, où il y a eu une longue histoire de dictature,
cette lutte est en cours et il nous reste encore un long chemin à parcourir.
Mais la vérité est qu'il se passe quelque chose.
Il y a des résultats :
des contrôles indépendants de la Banque mondiale et d'autres organisations
montrent que dans beaucoup de cas, la tendance est décroissante
en terme de corruption, la gouvernance s'améliore.
Une étude de la Commission Économique pour l'Afrique a montré
une tendance claire et en hausse de la gouvernance dans 28 pays africains.
Et laissez moi ajouter une dernière chose
avant que j'en finisse avec le thème de la gouvernance.
C'est que les gens parlent de la corruption, la corruption.
À chaque fois qu'ils en parlent
on pense immédiatement à l'Afrique.
Voilà l'image qu'on a : les pays africains. Mais laissez moi vous dire ceci :
si Alams a pu transférer huit millions de dollars vers un compte à Londres --
si les autres personnes ont pu amasser de l'argent, une somme estimée à
20 à 40 milliards maintenant des fonds des pays en voie de développement
et dormant à l'étranger dans les pays industrialisés -- s'ils sont capables de faire ça,
qu'est-ce que c'est? N'est-ce pas de la corruption ?
Dans ce pays, si vous acceptez de la marchandise volée, n'êtes-vous pas poursuivis ?
Donc quand on parle de ce type de corruption, rappelons nous
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté du globe --
où va l'argent et ce qui peut être fait pour y mettre fin.
Je travaille en ce moment sur une initiative, avec la Banque Mondiale,
sur la récupération d'actifs, en essayant de faire notre possible
pour récupérer l'argent transféré à l'étranger --
l'argent des pays en voie de développement -- pour que cet argent soit rendu.
Parce que si nous pouvons récupérer les 20 milliards de dollars qui dorment à l'étranger,
c'est une somme potentiellement plus importante pour certains pays
que celle de toute l'aide qui leur est apportée.
(Applaudissements)
La deuxième chose dont je souhaite parler c'est la volonté d'engager des réformes.
Les Africains, aprés -- ils sont fatigués, nous somme fatigués
d'être l'objet de la charité et de l'attention de tout le monde.
Nous sommes reconnaissants mais nous savons que
nous pouvons prendre en main nos destinées si nous avons la volonté d'engager des réformes.
Et ce qui se produit dans de nombreux pays africains en ce moment c'est la prise de conscience
que personne ne peut pas le faire à notre place. Nous devons le faire.
Nous pouvons encourager des partenaires à nous soutenir, mais nous devons faire le premier pas.
Il nous faut réformer nos économies, changer nos dirigeants,
devenir plus démocratiques, être plus ouverts au changement et à l'information.
Et c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
dans un des plus grands pays du continent, le Nigeria.
En fait, si vous n'êtes pas au Nigeria, vous n'êtes pas en Afrique.
Je veux que vous le sachiez.
(Rires)
Une personne sur quatre en Afrique sub-saharienne est nigériane,
et c'est le pays de 140 millions de personnes dynamiques -- des gens inorganisés --
mais des gens très intéressants. Vous ne vous ennuierez jamais.
(Rires)
Nous avons commencé à nous rendre compte
que nous devions nous prendre en charge et nous réformer.
Et avec le soutien d'un chef d'état
ayant eu la volonté, à l'époque, d'engager des réformes,
nous avons mis en place un programme complet de réformes
que nous avons nous-mêmes conçu.
Pas le Fonds Monétaire International. Pas la Banque Mondiale,
pour qui j'ai travaillé pendant 21 ans et dont je suis devenue une vice-présidente.
Personne ne peut le faire pour vous. Il faut le faire soit-même.
Nous avons mis en place un programme qui, d'une : désengagerait l'état
des entreprises dont il n'avait pas de raison de s'occuper.
L'état ne devrait pas s'occuper
de la production des biens et des services
parce qu'il est inefficace et incompétent.
Nous avons donc décidé de privatiser un grand nombre de nos entreprises.
(Applaudissements)
Cela -- en conséquence, nous a mené à libéraliser un nombre important de nos marchés.
Pouvez-vous croire qu'avant cette réforme --
qui a débuté à la fin de 2003, quand j'ai quitté Washington
pour prendre le poste de Ministre des Finances --
nous avions une entreprise de télécommunication qui n'avait été capable de développer
que 4 500 lignes terrestres en 30 ans d'existence ?
(Rires)
Avoir un téléphone était un luxe immense dans mon pays.
Vous ne pouviez pas en avoir. Il fallait verser un pot-de-vin.
Il faire des pieds et des mains pour avoir un téléphone.
Quand le Président Obasanjo a lancé et soutenu
la libéralisation du secteur des télécommunications,
nous sommes passés de 4 500 lignes terrestres à 32 millions de lignes GSM, un nombre qui croît encore.
Le marché nigérian des télécommunications est celui avec la deuxième plus forte croissance au monde,
après la Chine. Nous obtenons des investissements d'environ 1 milliard de dollars par an
dans les télécommunications. Et personne ne le sait, sauf quelques personnes avisées.
(Rires)
L'entreprise la plus avisée à arriver sur le marché
fut MTN de l'Afrique du Sud.
Et pendant les trois ans pendant lesquels je fus ministre des finances,
ils ont engrangé une moyenne de 360 millions de dollars de profits annuels.
360 millions sur un marché -- dans un pays qui est pauvre,
avec un revenu moyen par habitant juste en dessous de 500 dollars.
Il y a donc un marché.
Ils ne l'ont pas ébruité mais d'autres ont vite été au courant.
Les Nigérians eux-mêmes ont commencé à développer
quelques entreprises de télécommunications sans fil,
et trois ou quatre autres sont arrivées.
Mais le marché est immense,
et les gens ne le savent pas, ou alors il ne veulent pas le savoir.
La privatisation a donc été une des choses que nous avons faites.
L'autre initiative que nous avons prise est de mieux gérer nos finances.
Parce que personne ne va vous aider ou vous soutenir
si vous ne gérez pas bien vos finances.
Et le Nigeria, avec le secteur pétrolier, avait la réputation
d'être corrompu et de ne pas bien gérer ses finances publiques.
Qu'avons-nous donc essayé de faire ? Nous avons introduit une règle fiscale
supprimant le lien entre notre budget et le prix du pétrole.
Avant nous budgétisions nos dépenses en fonction de ce que nous rapportait le pétrole,
parce que le pétrole est le secteur qui rapporte le plus de revenus
dans l'économie : 70 pour cent de nos revenus proviennent du pétrole.
Une fois que ce lien fût supprimé, nous avons commencé à budgétiser nos dépenses
en fonction d'un prix du pétrole légèrement en dessous du prix réel
en économisant la différence.
Nous ne savions pas si nous pourrions réussir, la mesure était controversée.
Mais le résultat immédiat fût de réduire la volatilité
qui était présente jusque là en terme de notre développement économique --
quand le prix du pétrole augmentait, notre économie croissait très vite.
Quand il s'effondrait, notre économie s'effondrait aussi.
Et nous ne pouvions presque rien payer, les salaires, les dépenses de notre économie.
Nous avons pu réguler ce phénomène. Avant que je ne quitte mon poste, nous avions engrangé
27 milliards de dollars pour alimenter nos réserves. Alors que
lorsque je suis arrivée en 2003, nous avions sept milliards de dollars de réserves.
Quand je suis partie, nous avions presque atteint 30 milliards de dollars. Et
aujourd'hui nous avons environ 40 milliards de dollars de réserves
grâce à la bonne gestion de nos finances.
Et cela renforce notre économie, cela la rend stable.
Notre taux de change qui fluctuait tout le temps
est maintenant relativement stable et bien géré, ce qui permet au monde des affaires
d'avoir une prévisibilité des prix dans notre économie.
Nous avons réduit l'inflation de 28 pour cent à 11 pour cent.
Et notre PIB a augmenté de 2,3 pour cent en moyenne pendant la dernière décennie
à environ 6,5 pour cent maintenant.
Donc tous les changements et les réformes que nous avons mis en œuvre
se sont traduits par des résultats économiques mesurables.
Et sachant que nous voulions réduire notre dépendance au pétrole
et de diversifier -- et qu'il y a beaucoup d'opportunités
dans ce grand pays, comme dans beaucoup de pays africains --
le plus remarquable est que cette croissance est venue
non pas du seul secteur pétrolier mais aussi d'autres secteurs.
La croissance de l'agriculture a été de plus de 8 pour cent.
Le secteur des télécommunications n'a pas été le seul à croître, il en a été de même pour l'immobilier,
et je peux citer d'autres exemples. Cela illustre bien le fait
qu'une fois que la macro-économie fonctionne correctement,
les opportunités dans les autres secteurs sont énormes.
Nous avons des opportunités en agriculture, comme je l'ai dit.
Nous avons des opportunités dans les minerais solides. Nous avons beaucoup de minerais
dans lesquels personne n'a investi ou qui n'ont pas été explorés. Et nous avons réalisé
que sans une législation appropriée rendant cela possible,
cela n'arriverait pas. Nous nous sommes donc dotés d'un code minier
comparable aux meilleurs codes au monde.
Nous avons des opportunités dans le logement et l'immobilier.
Il n'y avait rien dans un pays de 140 millions de personnes --
pas de centres commerciaux qui vous sont familiers ici.
C'était pour quelqu'un une opportunité d'investir
qui enflamma l'imagination des gens.
Et maintenant, nous avons une situation oú les commerces de ce centre commercial
ont un chiffre d'affaires quatre fois supérieur à celui qu'ils avaient prévu.
Donc, des avancées immenses dans la construction, l'immobilier,
les marchés hypothécaires. Les services financiers :
nous avions 89 banques. Beaucoup trop ne s'attachant pas à leur rôle premier.
Nous les avons consolidées de 89 à 25 banques en exigeant
qu'elles augmentent leur capital social.
Celui-ci est passé d'environ 25 millions de dollars à 150 millions de dollars.
Ces banques sont maintenant consolidées et ce renforcement
du système bancaire a attiré beaucoup d'investissements extérieurs.
La banque Barclays du Royaume-Uni a apporté 500 millions.
Standard Chartered a apporté 140 millions.
Et je peux continuer. Toujours plus de dollars dans le système.
Nous faisons de même avec le secteur de l'assurance.
De même pour les services financiers, beaucoup d'opportunités.
Le tourisme, dans beaucoup de pays africains, est une grande opportunité.
Et c'est ce pour quoi beaucoup de gens connaissent l'Afrique de l'est :
la faune, les éléphants, et ainsi de suite.
Mais gérer le marché touristique de façon
à en faire vraiment profiter les gens est très important.
Que suis-je en train d'essayer de dire ? J'essaye de vous dire
qu'il y a une nouvelle vague qui déferle sur le continent.
Une nouvelle vague d'ouverture et de démocratisation dans laquelle, depuis 2000,
plus de deux tiers des pays africains ont organisé
des élections démocratiques avec plusieurs partis.
Toutes n'ont pas été parfaites, ou ne le seront,
mais la tendance est très claire.
J'essaye de vous dire qu'au cours des trois dernières années,
le taux moyen de croissance sur le continent a évolué
d'environ 2,5 pour cent à 5 pour cent par an.
C'est mieux que la performance de nombreux pays de l'OCDE.
Il est donc clair que les choses changent.
Les conflits sont en recul sur le continent ;
il y en avait environ 12 conflits il y a une décennie,
il y en a maintenant trois ou quatre conflits,
L'un des plus terribles, bien sûr, est celui du Darfour.
Et comme vous le savez, il y a l'effet de voisinage où
si quelque chose se passe dans une partie du continent,
il semble que tout le continent en souffre.
Mais il faut savoir que ce continent n'est pas --
est un continent de nombreux pays, pas d'un seul.
Et si nous sommes maintenant descendus à trois ou quatre conflits,
cela veux dire qu'il y a beaucoup d'opportunités d'investissement
dans des économies excitantes, stables, et en croissance,
où il y a plein d'opportunités.
Et je souhaite faire une remarque sur cet investissement.
Le meilleur moyen d'aider les Africains aujourd'hui
est de les aider à voler de leurs propres ailes.
Et le meilleur moyen de le faire est d'aider à créer des emplois.
Il n'y aucun problème à lutter contre le paludisme et d'y mettre de l'argent
et de sauver la vie des enfants. Ce n'est pas ce que je dis. Tout ça est très bien.
Mais imaginez l'impact sur une famille : si les parents ont un emploi
et s'assurent que leurs enfants vont à l'école,
alors ils peuvent acheter les médicaments pour lutter eux-mêmes contre la maladie.
S'il vous est possible d'investir dans des endroits où vous pouvez gagner de l'argent
tout en créant des emplois et en aidant les gens à voler de leurs propres ailes,
n'est-ce pas une opportunité merveilleuse ? N'est-ce pas la chose à faire ?
Et je souhaite souligner que certaines des meilleures personnes dans lesquelles investir
sur le continent sont les femmes.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai un CD avec moi. Je suis navrée de ne pas l'avoir dit à temps.
Autrement, j'aurais souhaité vous le montrer.
Il est intitulé, « L'Afrique : prête à faire des affaires.»
Et c'est une vidéo qui a reçu un prix
du meilleur documentaire de l'année.
Notez que la femme qui l'a réalisé
sera en Tanzanie, où se déroulera la prochaine session en juin.
Mais ce documentaire montre des Africains, des femmes en particulier, qui
contre toute attente ont développé des entreprises, dont certaines de calibre mondial.
Une des femmes dans cette vidéo, Adenike Ogunlesi,
fabrique des vêtements pour enfants --
ce qu'elle a commencé comme passe-temps s'est transformé en entreprise.
Elle mélange des matériaux africains, comme nous l'avons,
avec des matériaux venus d'ailleurs.
Donc, elle fabriquera une petite salopette avec du velours côtelé,
en y intégrant des matériaux africains. Des concepts très créatifs.
L'entreprise a atteint le niveau où elle a même reçu une commande de Wal-Mart.
(Rires)
Pour 10 000 pièces.
Cela montre que nous avons des personnes capables de faire des choses.
Et les femmes sont appliquées : elles sont déterminées ; elles travaillent dur.
Je pourrais continuer à donner des exemples :
Béatrice Gakuba du Ruanda, qui a lancé une entreprise horticole
et qui exporte maintenant aux enchères au rabais à Amsterdam chaque matin,
et qui emploie 200 autres femmes et hommes pour travailler avec elle.
Cependant, beaucoup d'entre elles manquent de capitaux pour se développer,
parce que personne ne croit en dehors de nos pays
que nous sommes capables de faire ce qu'il faut. Personne ne pense en terme de marché.
Personne ne pense qu'il y a une opportunité.
Mais je suis ici pour affirmer que ceux qui ratent le coche maintenant,
l'auront manqué à jamais.
Donc si vous souhaitez être en Afrique, pensez à investir.
Pensez aux Béatrices, pensez aux Adenikes de ce monde,
qui font des choses incroyables qui les projettent
dans l'économie globale, tout en s'assurant
que leurs semblables, hommes et femmes, soient employés,
et que les enfants de ces ménages reçoivent une éducation
parce que leurs parents gagnent un revenu adéquat.
Je vous invite donc à explorer les opportunités.
Quand vous irez en Tanzanie, écoutez attentivement,
parce que je suis sûre que vous entendrez parler des diverses occasions
dans lesquelles vous aurez la possibilité de vous investir pour le bien
pour le bien du continent, pour le peuple et pour vous-même.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)